okay let's get started welcome to this
session about developing microservices
with dapper
it's great to be here my name is
jocobian i work at a company called
active solution back in stockholm sweden
uh i'm an azure mvp i have a lot of
interest in not just cloud architecture
also devops
i've written a few books on the topic
which is nothing that i really recommend
uh unless you're interested in wasting a
lot of time without making any real
money
but it was a good experience anyway and
uh it's great to be back here in oslo
actually i used to work for a norwegian
company for for many years so i have run
into a few old colleagues and friends
here
so so
really nice to be here
and so this talk is about dapper which
is a framework for kind of developing
microservices so
just to set the context here you know
what is hard about microservices and
actually there's a lot of things that is
hard with
working or developing with microservices
but if you think about the kind of the
the core idea behind microservices where
you take your system you break them down
into smaller pieces
where each service
could be potentially developed by their
own team
and ideally each team should be able to
select their own technology stack their
own type of storage you know the
technology that really fits that service
um and if you do this right that could
really give you a lot of benefits
and really create agile teams we can
work at speed and you know develop and
deploy in their service without
worrying about the rest of the system
but the kind of the flip side of that is
that now you have instead of have like
this big uh homogeneous system you have
a lot of smaller services where each
service have like a different technology
stack different platform different way
of you know building
uh packaging deploying that service
so it's a lot of things you need to
build and you know since this is now a
distributed system you need to think
about things like how do you do tracing
like distributed tracing how do you do
things like service discovery uh
resilience what do you do when you when
your service call fails and and so on
and these are things that it's like
cross-cutting concerns it's not really
tied to your your business domain right
this is technical things that you just
need to solve
and it's not that this is super hard or
super complicated
uh but you need to do it and you need to
do it in all these services and again
this could be now
one service could be developed in dot
net core another one could be java the
third could be python right different
type of storage so so a lot of things to
to worry about
and this is really the the core idea
about behind that but to try to to make
this easier for you try to codify
best practices within this uh this area
so that burst stands for distributed
application runtime
so this is an open source project um you
can read all about it at the dapper i o
uh and they had they went like generally
available for three or four months ago
so it's it's production support for for
this
runtime
and the core goals behind the upper is
to kind of build these best practices uh
building blocks that you can use so
again so you don't have to write this
code
to kind of implement all the things that
you need to implement and it's not tied
to any particular language or framework
today i will show you a demo in the
dotted core but supports really any kind
of language that you want to use which
is again really core idea with
microservices you shouldn't be tied into
a specific technology stack
um and it's a community driven so it's a
completely open source you can join
their their weekly standups if you want
to and kind of
affect the the the future of this
project
uh and it's not also it's also agnostic
in terms of where you want to run this
so you can run this on premise on your
your local machine on your servers
uh on really on any cloud uh so so
kubernetes is one of the
kind of
fitting platforms but there are other
options as well
uh and also importantly it's extensible
and pluggable so these components that
implements these building blocks you can
you know you can build new ones and and
new ones are being developed
as we speak
so here are the list of the the current
building blocks um so just to mention a
few other now is
the first one which is really really
really
obvious one is a service to service
invocation so of course you need a way
to
call uh you know
make call between your services
um and you know when you're building
distributed systems that consists of
multiple services and these services
could be running on you know multiple
machines you need a way to find where
where is my service actually located
right now and i shouldn't have to worry
about that i should just be able to make
a call to a service and then something
should do the service discovery for me
we have state management so this is
basically a kind of key value an
abstraction of a key value store uh so
you can store things in like a redis
cache cosmos db and so on
and it's not just for storing and
receiving value it also solves like
these problems of for example doing
handling transient failures doing
transactions across multiple rights
these kind of things that you shouldn't
have to write yourself this is things
that the people can implement for you
test it and then you should just be able
to use it
publish subscribe very common pattern
for doing you know event driven
distributed systems
resource binding and triggers this is a
way for letting your applications
communicate with with other systems for
example being triggered by an event
outside of your system
or making a call to some external api
for example
so again there will there are now a lot
of already implemented components that
just make this a lot easier for you
and there's a few more blocks there's an
election an actor building block which
is an implementation of the virtual
actor pattern
very specific pattern so if you're
interested in that definitely check it
out i won't mention it in this talk but
it's there
observability
again super important so you get things
like metrics distributed tracings which
will help you to troubleshoot your
system
uh which again is just harder when you
have now a distributed system with many
running things at the same time how do
you actually know what you know when you
get a bug in one service how do you know
which service called that service you
want to be able to trace it all the way
back just to make it easier for you to
define the errors
so but what's common about all these
building blocks now is that
um
these are now you can you communicate or
you use them through standard protocols
like http or grpc and this is an
important point now
because it means that that's the reason
why it's not tied to a specific language
or or you know runtime anything that can
speak http or grpc
will be able to use dapper because
that's how you communicate with it
so so that's a very uh
that that's a choice they made um
and what they're using to to implement
this is something called the the side
car the sidecar is really a distributed
system pattern it's a design pattern
it's very very common
so
if you take a look at an application
that consists of two services and these
two services uh wants to talk to each
other so we want to do service
invocation right
so instead of just finding out where is
service b running right now and make a
call to it
instead of that we're going to
communicate with our side car
so when you're using dapper
every time you launch your service it
will have a side car so a separate
process running next to it and that's
what you communicate with
and you do that using again http or grpc
you can select that yourself
so when i want to communicate with my
with service b here i will actually just
make a call to the dapper sidecar it
will actually make a call to service b
sidecar and then that sidecar will now
call that service
so it's a level of indirection here
which actually this is where all the
functionality and kind of the magic
about that
happens
so it will do the service discovery for
me i just need to know basically the
name of the service and the method i
want to call and the dapper sidecar will
now
find it for me in addition to that
it will add things like
the observability for example so the
tracing and login metrics and so on it's
just i get that for free i don't need to
do anything
to get that
it also secures the communication
between
the side cars so you get the tls for
free as well which is very nice
so for the rest of the building blocks
that you want to use you need to specify
okay which of these building blocks do i
want to use and and which
implementations of it
and this is done using a component yaml
files you specify a component file
that that says which for example which
do i want to use a state store or not
and if i want to use a save store which
type of state store do i want to use
redis or cosmos db or something like
that so i specify this in a yaml file
which i'll use then when i run my system
so and the aml files again this this is
now allows you to use things like the
state stores you can use the
the published subscribes building blocks
the resource bindings and again there
are now many many implementations of
these building blocks so you have a lot
of different options here
so again for example if using state
store you can you can select the store
your state in redis in cosmos db in uh
aws dynamic db so this is a long list
and it's you know it keeps growing
because this is community driven
so so the number of options here will
just
rise along the way here
so again sidecar model you have your
application it speaks to this to the
dapper sidecar
and this is the the
the
how the url actually looks um
beneath the surface
uh
and so the default port here will be
three three five oh
um and you know this will be running
next to your service that's really all
you need to know
and again if for example if you want to
do a
service invocation you can see that
that's the first example there so if
slash invoke that's how you actually
call for example the
the method called new order on the cart
service
uh the next one is the the states so
the url format is slash state and then
the name of your state store and for
example
give me the item with id
item item67 for example
so this is really all you need to do to
to use these building blocks just codify
this this
http urls you can also use grpc as i
mentioned
now there are many sdks available which
makes it even more easy you don't
actually have to write this http code
and i will show you an example that in
the demo later
so it makes it even easier but it is
important to realize it's just http
which allows you to use anything you
want that can speak http
you just need to make sure that that
your dapper's sidecar is running next to
your application
the component files can look like this
this is a yaml file of course everything
is yaml nowadays because we all love it
and uh
so and kind of the key thing here is the
type the type of the components in this
case this is the
uh the azure service bus
and depending on the type here it will
have a set of you know metadata that is
specific to that
service of course so in the in the case
of a service bus you need to define a
connection string and so on
uh and then you can see that it the the
component also has a name in this case
the name is message bus
and that's really all i need to know
later on in my program if i want to kind
of
talk to this
to this service the azure service
service i just need to refer to the name
message bus
and then dapper will handle that for me
so it's really a nice abstraction that
that
keeps all these implementation details
away from your application and just
makes this really pluggable which is
really nice
so again i'm just going to walk through
a few of these just to kind of explain
how it actually works and then i will
dive into a demo uh so
again service invocation like this is
really basic
this is something all you know basically
all systems will use
again if you want to call to for example
this case we have the front end it makes
a call to the card service it actually
calls uh the dapper so you'll make a
post uh to your adapter sidecar in this
case i'm calling the
api checkout method on my cart service
and i post some data to it
the diaper sidecar will then speak to
the other side car
and this communication is always done
using grpc
because it just is much faster than http
so you can select http or grpc when you
speak to the sidecar but you know
between the sidecars it's always the rpc
and then that title call will then
actually make the post to the card
service and then return the answer back
to to the front end and you don't really
notice this it's just done behind the
scene
but again in addition to do this service
discovery you get things like uh
automatic retries for example if you get
transient failures it will actually
retry it for you
you get secure communication and also
you get the observability kind of for
free so so really helps you with with
debugging your systems
when or if they will fail
also to understand things like
performance and so on
state management again this is a key
value
implementation but again a value could
of course is a document you can you can
store any complex orbit in here
so again if you want to store something
you'll make a post to the the state url
specifying the name of the state store
and then you pass in a key and a value
basically
so again this could be a simple integer
string or it could be a complex document
and again dapper will then store the
data for me and depending on my
component yaml file
uh it will be stored now in in this this
date store that i that i chose be it
redis or cosmos and so on
and of course you can be able to
retrieve this information later on after
you saved it so you can you can do a get
there's also a query api
that you can use again these are
abstractions now
because they need to work with all of
these underlying implementations
and of course there will be cases when
this is not enough if you have like a
heavy investment in in cosmos db and you
you do a lot of weird things
this this building block might not be
enough and then you can just you know
select to go directly to cosmos db but
in many cases this building blocks will
be enough for your services and if you
have many services you could have like
20 50 100 services it just makes a lot
of sense to to keep it simple
in my opinion you don't need to
complicate things by by writing this
stuff yourself but if you need to you
can of course do that you don't have to
use dapper for everything right
again you have things like optimistic
concurrency you get that for free
automatically tries again you can also
do transactions if you do
multiple rights
so these are things that you typically
might miss to do maybe you don't think
about it until you're actually in
production
here you just you can get that for for
free
pub sub again you're starting to see the
pattern here when you you want to
publish an event you do that through
your sidecar you can select the type of
you know message bus that you want to
use
so read this or rabbit mq and service
bus
azure service bus so you publish an
event and you can specify uh any number
of subscribers uh to that
to the topic of your
of your service bus
so of course very very common pattern in
distributed systems event-driven systems
to do the pub sub communication form
again it has things like at least once
guarantee you can specify message time
to live and so on
and these are also things that being
developed is being improved along the
way of course
so if you are starting to use dapper you
will actually you know you will you will
get more functionality along the way
because this is a thing that people are
working on and it's open source so you
know you can contribute yourself
okay so let's dive into a demo here so
how you actually get started with that
but how it actually works
so i'm having a super simple uh
uh
sample application here with three
components so we have like a web
application we have an api
that will actually store an order for me
and then i have a kind of a background
thing called a warehouse api
that will eventually listen to an event
when an order is created and then do
something
so i'm gonna you know try to show some
of these building blocks how it actually
works
so of course we'll do service invocation
between the the web and the api
we'll do pub sub so you know when we get
an order in the api we'll also raise or
publish an event
that the api will listen to
so we'll store the state in either redis
or cosmos db i think we'll do both
uh if we're time we'll also see how we
can trigger this from the outside world
so for example if we get an event on a
service bus how can we trigger our
application
uh from that
and also an example of
the output bindings as they're called
the triggers and so in this case uh i'll
send a message through twilio every time
i receive this order publish event
so that's kind of the the scope of this
demo
so let's uh jump straight into vs code
and
so these are the three uh
uh
applications that i talked about the api
in the web and the the warehouse api and
this is the standard.net core it's
better than score applications
and just to show you you know how do you
how do you run dapper with your
applications because the thing is you
need to have this uh the sidecar running
next to your application
so one way of doing that you know if i
would run this application in the normal
way i would do a you know dotnet run and
it will run my dozen core applications
so you know you know that of course
but in this case i you know i need to
run my application and adapter sidecar
so
actually what i could do is to use the
dapper cli
so i'm going to zoom in a little bit
here
so
add the dapper cli that's a
see how you can use for example to run
the sidecar and also do a few other
things and so what i do now i'll do a
dapper run
and uh first up
i need to specify the the app id so
that's the the identification of my
application that's how other
applications or services will
know how to to communicate with my
service
so when i run the order api service i
will give it the app by the order uh
order api and again that's that's all
the other servers need to know
i also need to specify the port that my
application listens sensitive so the
sidecar can actually communicate with my
service that's the app port
i can specify the the dapper http port
so by default this is a 3500 so i
actually didn't have to to specify it
here
but if you want to run multiple services
on on one machine like i will do now you
actually have to make sure that that you
know you can't listen to the same port
so if i would run another one i would
have to specify a different port here
and then at the end there i have the
dotnet run so again
i want to start my application as well
so the adapter cli actually lets me
start the sidecar and my application in
one simple command
so to show this i will run
and
it actually now shows me when it's when
i run it like this it will show me the
output from the side car so everything
in white here that's coming from the
side car
so there's a lot of details here you
know it initializes it reads component
files and and you know yeah data a lot
of stuff
i can also see the output here in blue
which comes from from my application
that the standard asp.net core output so
it's just mixed into one log output
which is quite nice
so again now i have my order api running
and
so if i would just go to the normal
endpoint here
for example slash order
uh i'll just hit my api endpoint so now
i'm not really using that button i'm
just hitting my my api
uh but what i could do now is i could
actually access the same endpoint
uh through dapper
so
you know that that's the url that i just
hit but i can also use this url so let's
just
hit it first
and of course i get back the same result
so if you remember from
the slide that i showed you that's the
the url format for service invocation
so now i actually communicate to my
endpoint through my the dapper sidecar
so i do slash invoke i do the name of
the of the service order api and then
you have the the method which is called
the order in this case
so that's all you need to know to
actually
speak to the service and what's
important to realize here is that i now
i don't have to know where that service
is running i just speak to my sidecar in
the first example i needed to know that
it's actually listening to port
and of course now this is just one
machine this could be running on on a
distributed system with multiple
machines so service discovery like this
just makes a lot of things a lot simpler
okay so
that is uh you know that's that's how
you use the cli now
typically you don't want to you know run
this cli for every every service that
you're running you could have like you
know 10 or 15 services in your solution
so you typically don't want to you know
hit that run for each of your service
when you're trying to to run them and
debug them and so on
so if you're using vs code um
there is a nice extension
for dapper
and what this does it has a few
different functionalities but one of
them is to make it easier for you to
to work with dapper in vs code so
it will actually help you to to create
this launch and test configuration so if
you if you're working with vs code you
know that you can create launch
configurations to you know
specify how how do you start and debug
your applications and um so it will
actually help you to scaffold these
things automatically
and
so for example if we're if we're going
to run the order api i have a lot of
configuration here called order api
adapter
so it's actually a standard
asp.net.net core launch configuration
with with two different
or two differences it has this
pre-launch task here
and then they have with the post debug
task here so again the pre-launch task
if you just hit quickly into here this
now comes with extension and this is now
actually what starts the sidecar
so here again you can see
a little bit of the information that i
passed manually to the dapper cli here i
just specify that in this task so i give
it the app id i give it the port the
http port and a few other things
and this is nice now because when i have
all this in place i can just hit f5 like
usual and it will start all my my
services with the dapper side cars i can
debug them you know just like any other
application
because you want to keep that you know
that inner flow
to have that fast
okay so
let's see how we actually use that for
now in an application so if you go to
the the web application uh which is just
super super simple i will create an
order
uh when i do that i want to call the the
order api here
and
so what i do know i i will instantiate
the the dapper clients and i'm using the
sdk now the the
the new get the package for dapper
and uh let me just show you i already
installed it before
so i have this adapter client nuget
package installed for me and this just
makes it easier for me now i don't have
to to create that url format that i
showed you before i can just
i can use this
this object model instead so i'll create
a client and if i do
see what's in there
you can see that we have now methods for
this various building blocks so for
example we have the invoke method that's
how we do service invocation
i have invoked binding to communicate
with the external systems we have
published events and so on
so this will create the the correct url
formats for me so it just makes it a lot
simpler
so let's call the api then so i'll just
do an await here
and let's do an evoke method of sync
so in this case i'm going to post the
order to the api so i'm going to do
pass it as a type argument and
so for for the parameters now the only
thing i really need to know now again is
the the name of the service that i want
to talk to and the method
so the first one is the app id which is
now order api right that's what we
specified
uh and the method in this case is just
called the order the default post method
and the last argument is the actual data
that i want to pass
so i'm just going to pass the order here
so that's really all i need to do to
actually do service invocation so the
web will now call the api
uh let's head over to the api now to see
because i don't want to just pass you
know the order around i actually want to
save it as well
so we will eventually
wind up here in the post order method in
my api it will receive the order
so again i will
create this one
and again you can do
you can actually inject this i don't i
don't have to do it like this way but
just to make it clear what actually
happens i'll create this client uh
kind of manually in each method
so in this case i want to store this
data so i i do a client and then i could
oops
client.save state
and again i could pass the type here
because i want to save a type order
and again now i need to specify um the
state store the name of my state store
so i'm just going to pass actually a
state store here i will get back to that
and it specified the key for my data so
in this case i would typically use the
the id for the
for the order
and finally i need to pass
the value so the order itself
so that's it
and let's run this so let's set a
breakpoint here
and we'll do an f5
so that's my beautiful web page where i
can create an order
and let's just type something here and
you see hoodie
and i want to have three of them
so we hit the breakpoint here
and so you can see now they've actually
come to the to the api endpoint so it
was actually properly called from my web
did the service invocation to the api
and it also stored my
my order here so let's just take a look
at the order uh the order that was
passed here so we can see it has the ndc
hoodie the quantity was three and so on
uh and it was saved so
okay but you know
what actually happened where is that
order saved now so by default when
you're when you're installing dapper
um it will actually also spin up a redis
instance for you just to make it really
easy to get started and to work locally
so
by default you will get the state store
which is called state store which is
using redis as as its
backing service
so to actually show you where it ended
up let's i have a relish explorer
here and
so you can see now it actually has this
new entry here that was just created and
this is actually where my data went up
you can see the data coming in here
so this has happened automatically and
uh
the reason why this actually works is
again when you install dapper
you will get this uh you know in your
user profile you get this dot adapter
folder inside there you have some
default components and configuration if
you go into this
component directory you can see we have
two yaml files here one for pub sub and
one for state store
so just to open this one
and zoom in a little bit
this is the default states where you get
so again uses redis on your local
machine and that's you know that's why
that save state just worked without me
having to do anything
extra
so
super simple to get started
and again the name is the key here so
that's why i specified state store in my
code
so so the name is is really the key here
but
let's say let's say i don't want to use
you know redis for my state store i want
to use cosmos for example
then i need to provide my my own
component files so
i have a folder now which is empty
called components
copy
an existing one here so let's drag this
one here and take a look at it
so
this is the same as a component file it
has the same name state store but in
this case i'm using state azure cosmos
db
and then i have some some information
that's specific to this one and again
you don't you don't have to
you know have secret information like i
do now you can you can use for example a
key vault and tie that in automatically
uh so this is just
simpler
maybe maybe for you to understand
so again the type is the cosmos db the
metadata is you know how how can
actually dapper will communicate with
the with the cosmos
so let's run the same code again
and
to do that i need to stop my side course
because it needs to to reload this com
this file and i need to do one more
thing i need to specify now the path
where my component files are are located
so i will add
to all of these three i will add a
component path
which is uh
to
dot slash components
so that's actually how dapper will know
where my component files are
so to my three three different the api
warehouse and the web so now it knows
where to look for it so let's do
an f5
and run the same thing again
so let's do an ndc hoodie
too
and we had a breakpoint
just run that
and again now uh we shouldn't we
shouldn't see a new entry here and we
don't so the reason for that now of
course is that it actually was stored in
uh my cosmos live account
and
just to show you that i'm not lying
let's just take a look here
so this is my the cosmos db account that
i'm using and let's check the order one
and we should see one item here now
maybe we could zoom in a little bit here
so again you can see the same
information you have the item and
quantity and then you have a lot of kind
of customer specific stuff uh but that
wasn't anything that i needed to
actually to worry about it was just done
automatically by dapper so you can see
how easy it is to just plug a component
in and the communication will just you
know work without me having to write any
code for it
i could potentially run the redis
locally and then use cosmos db for my
testing and production environment if i
want to
um
but i think the main thing is that you
don't have to do the implementation
yourself uh
the
the possibility of switching opponents
different type stores that's nice but
it's not you know that's not so common
that you do that it's more about the
having the kind of the best practice
implementation there
okay so
let's uh move on to
and to do some pub sub
um so when i save this order i also want
to to raise an event to let anyone know
that actually i
stored a new order so i use the same
client object
in this case i will do now a publish
event
so add the publish event to
let's pass the order
and i will give it the name so this is
corresponding to the state store name
like we did before now i need to specify
the name of my my pub sub store so
i have a component file that i will use
and the name of that one is order pub
sub
and then specify the topic so this is
what the subscribers actually will
listen to so you can have you know
multiple topics and the subscribers will
listen to that topic
and this one is called the order
and again the last one is the data
itself so i'll just do an order
so that's it that's everything i need to
do
and
let's head over to to the last one the
last service the warehouse api
which we should then
listen to this order and
uh
what i need to do now is actually we can
leave the method like this
and
now we just need to add some component
files here so i need to specify what
kind of pub sub service or component i
want to use
so in this case uh let's grab run from
here
i'll use this one the pub sub which is
under the hood just using redis so
that's the default but i could for
example use the azure service bus here
if i want to
uh so that's for publishing events then
to in order to actually subscribe to the
events
i can for example also use a component
file for that
so i have a subscription file here this
could actually also be done in code
um
but for the subscribers here i specify
the name of the pub sub the topic i want
to listen to and where those messages
should be routed so it should be routed
to the order created endpoint in the
services
and here you can also see uh the scopes
at the end here
oops sorry um
so that's actually how i can filter
these events so because i don't want to
have all the services uh having this
event routed to them i want to specify
only for which which subscribers are
actually interested in this one so in
this case it's the warehouse api that
should actually receive it
so actually let's do one more thing at
the same time
before we run that one because i also
want to show you an example of
actually let's wait with that one we'll
come back to that one
so
let's stop the side course because we
added some new components
and let's stop here
so let's just build it and run it
and i think i had a break point
at the end here so let's send another
order
test
and i guess we get a break point here in
actually after the publish event
let's keep running
see
did i add in a break point in that
method
i did so it actually should have been
called now
let's see did we add this the
subscription
we did let's stop the side cars
okay
let's try that one more time
so it should actually should hit my my
endpoint over here
let's put a breakpoint there as well
send this one again
okay so for some reason it actually
didn't hit my api endpoint here so it
should i'm not sure why that didn't work
uh okay but anyway that usually works uh
when i do this demo uh but for some
reason the pubs didn't work here
um but okay let's let's uh continue to
kind of the last block that i want to
show you
which was actually supposed to run here
but instead let's run that from
the order api instead
um because i want to show you how you
can also
trigger or kind of communicate with
external systems here both like like
input and output
so what one way we could do here is to
send a message every time we get an
order
so i'll do an invoke
binding here i want to send a message
through the twilio service
so
i have a twitter component defined
so if you have it's a very nice cloud
service for sending various types of
messages
and let's go to
my folder here let's copy the twilio
component
so again the information to my account
would like to now send a text message
and the name of the component is twilio
so that means when i write this code
i will specify
the name here
so i'll do a sync i'll add the name of
the component
and
the operation in this case will be a
create and
then i will also add a text message so
let's type order created
and just pass in the order id for
example
so let's run this one
see if this one makes me a little bit
happier
it should work
some quantity
and we get a break point
first one let's run again
it ran through here
and well you probably didn't hear but i
actually got a text message here very
powerful demonstration
you can come up afterwards and actually
see i actually got a text message
it says order created and it's a nice
grid
okay
but again one line of code that's all i
needed to actually communicate within
this case twilio so that's an example of
an output binding where i communicate
with with an external system like
outbound
another way is to trigger the system
from the outside world using inbound
so let's say that now instead of just
receiving orders from the web
application i also want to be able to
reach it through a service bus from
coming from an external system
so
let's try that
and again to do that i need to have a
component file to specify you know which
which service pass should i use
so let's stop this one and let's add the
last one here it's the
the binding here to the service bus
let's copy it here
and again i'm using uh
this in this case the type is the
bindings azure service bus cues uh and
then you know connection string and so
on to specify how to communicate with
that service bus
and uh
since i have that now i should just be
able to run this
and
let's head over to
my service bus
so
that per demo
thank you so you know if you're using
azure service bus you know that you can
actually go in here and just send a test
message so i'll use the service bus
explorer and
maybe we can zoom in a bit
okay never mind so i'll just send a
sample order here so i'll just select
json here and then i'm just going to
copy
a sample order in json format here so i
just and i just need to pass the item
and the quantity here really
like that
and send it and you can see now that it
immediately hit my break point
so
let's check the order that come in here
you can see racing car 42
so again now i actually didn't write any
code at all i just added the component
file and that message is now received
automatically from the service bus and
so you see how easy it is now to build
connected systems like that both
synchronous uh and asynchronous with
very very little code and and
it's not again not just the
functionality of actually communicating
with that particular service it's also
handling things like uh
retries in case of failures and
observability and so on
okay let's uh switch back to the
presentation and talk a little bit about
hosting these things so hopefully you
got a good sense of how you actually
work with these things to how to get
started
and uh
so when you're hosting this you can do
this self-hosted this is really what i
did now on my local machine and you
could do the same thing on you know in
the production environment but typically
you would use something like kubernetes
for your platform
uh now you can also use azure container
apps which is actually announced in
preview at ignite which is a new really
kind of a serverless kubernetes service
which will eventually make it just much
more simpler for you to host your
microservices without having to know a
lot of details about for example
kubernetes
so but in the case of self-hosted you
know we did this adapter run as the the
slide shows here
um so you run your application you're on
your sidecar
and the other things actually runs like
docker containers on your machine so the
the red this the the zipkin for the
tracing and so on that will actually run
like docker containers on your on on
your
machine where you run running these
things
but again i'd say this is mostly for
local development i would say
when you do self-hosted so if you're uh
if you're on kubernetes um what you can
do through the dapper cli you can do
dapper init
k it will actually deploy the dapper
components to your cluster
uh and then you can actually just deploy
your your application of course but also
the component files you can take them
just as they are and deploy them into
kubernetes uh because dapper actually
creates what's called a custom resource
definition so then we'll actually
understand the same component files
so it's really really simple to take
this application that i just showed you
and just deploy it to kubernetes i just
deployed the same files that i just
showed you and in your deployment
manifests where i marked the red square
there you add a few annotations to it
and this is the trigger for that for
dapper to tell you this is actually that
per application i want you to start that
per side car that's the dapper io
enabled annotation here
so that's kind of the magic and again
then you have these different things
that i showed you before the app id the
protocol and so on and i'll actually
show you that in a quick demo afterwards
so again what actually happens uh you
know behind the scene is that when a
cubit is when you spin up a pod
incubators with your container in it
the dapper operator will also inject the
sidecar into that pod just by magic you
don't have to worry about it but again
the communication work
and you still you just need to know the
name of the service talk you don't need
to change anything you can run it
exactly in the same way as you do
locally but in this time it's in
kubernetes
and
just i wanted also to show you the
possibility of now using azure container
apps if you're an azure so this is
something you should look into if you're
doing microservices but maybe you
haven't invested a lot of time and
effort to learn kubernetes
and i think we'll see more of this type
of solution going forward from from
various cloud providers just to kind of
abstract away the complexity of
kubernetes
and
so to deploy your application you just
do an ac container upgrade and you just
deploy it and you just pay for what
you're using but you can also enable
dapper so if you're saying i want to run
this as a dapper deprived application
you just add these extra parameters so
enable dapper and again specifying the
port the app id and so on
uh
and of course this is much much simpler
than to you know to actually spin up a
kubernetes cluster and learn all about
this various deployment manifests and so
on so it's still in preview but check it
out if you're interested in
microservices on azure
and
so actually i have deployed this
application that i just showed you i
have deployed them both to a kubernetes
cluster and to
an azure container app
so i just want to show you
what it actually looks like
so i have a folder called deployment
here and i have one for kubernetes and
one for container apps
let's just take a look you can see i
have four files here one of them is
related to tracing so i'll also show you
how the tracing actually looks like but
i have one deployment manifest for my
three different applications the api the
web and the warehouse api
and again if we take a look at this you
can see that well if you're if you're
familiar with kubernetes you should
recognize this as a standard deployment
manifest
but
what's specific here is this thing
i added this this dapper annotations and
again this is what actually would
uh automatically spin up this adapter
sidecar next to my application and
specifying the app id the port
and and the config in this case
that's all i need to add actually and
the second part is the components so
this is now again exactly the same files
that i just showed you
i just switched a few things i don't
want to use
actually i need to specify the
name of the reddit service in my
kubernetes so actually the end point
will be a little bit different but but
it's the same component files um
and you can just apply them deploy them
in exactly the same way as you would do
with it with a
kubernetes
manifest so you know to deploy this
all i need to do now is to
find a little front here somewhere
and go to
deploy
so i have my files here i can go to the
components and i can do a cube capital
apply
and all the files and it will just
deploy my my component manifest it says
unchanged because i did that before
and then i would do the same thing with
my with my deployment manifests
so to show you this uh i will take a
peek inside my my cluster to see what's
running in there
so we can see i have my three different
applications where the order api or the
web and the warehouse oops sorry
i also have a redis
deployment running in there so i can use
redis if i want to
and also at the zipkin which is the for
the distributed tracing
so let's take a look at
how we can access it so we have the
public endpoint here for the web
so again let's
take that one and browse to it
and not very impressively it looks of
course exactly the same thing but now
it's running inside kubernetes and i can
use it in the same way
and i got text message
uh but again i didn't the application is
completely untouched i didn't have to
change anything i'm using dapper so it
knows how to find the other components i
just added the deployment manifest
deployed it into kubernetes and it's
kind of it just worked
and that that's a really nice aspect of
using dapper i think because everything
is just
handled by these components
and one of the building blocks that i
didn't show you before is the tracing
now so i just want to quickly show you
that one
so i exposed
the zipkin
as a public ip just to make it easier to
to take a look at it so
this is the standard zip key on the
dashboard and of course you could you
can also export it to a lot of different
tracing providers here
but you get a few things
for free here you get a really small
diagram
so if you have very good eyes you can
actually see like the communication
flowing here so you can see the the
order web is calling the order api which
is called in the warehouse api and so on
um and you can also see uh traces here
which might be you know potentially is
more interesting
so here i can see
the thing that i just did a few a few
seconds ago
and you can see a lot of information
about there like how many times were
this called service was this call down
which service called which service and
so on so i could actually you know dive
into this one particular call and i can
see that they order web called the older
api and so on so this is just for free i
didn't you know write a single piece of
code to do this i just enabled tracing
in
in dapper and i got this kind of for
free
so
that's that's really really nice
i also deployed it to azure container
apps that i mentioned before
so for the capabilities part of course i
had to create a kubernetes cluster and
set up permissions and so on so that's a
little bit of a work and i need to kind
of understand kubernetes
in terms of container apps
it's kind of much easier
because i don't need to spin up anything
first i just deploy my application and
actually will deploy it for me somewhere
in the cloud and i will just pay for it
you know pay for how much i actually use
it
so i have a deployment script here so
again this is all that it takes to
create or actually to deploy an
application so i use the ac container
app create i don't have to use dapper of
course i can i can deploy any containers
application like this
so i just specify an environment and an
environment is actually created up here
that this is really the only command you
need to run first to create the
environment
so
under the hood this is actually a
namespace in a kubernetes cluster
somewhere but you don't you know really
have to know about that you just create
an environment for your application so
it's like an isolated boundary where the
the services can can talk to each other
and then you deploy your application
into that environment so you just
specify that here you're specifying in
the image
if it should be publicly available or
not with ingress and again i have this
uh enable dapper and adapter information
added to it
so
let's take a look at
what i have here so i could do a
ac container app
list just to see what container apps do
i have in in this group and it will show
me
i hope three container apps so again the
web the api and that that warehouse api
is running there
one of them now has a public endpoint
because i specify that the other one is
just internal they just need to be run
from the inside
by default you will get this pretty
strange url
uh
of course eventually when this thing
goes ga you you can attach a custom
domain to it and so on
um but you get this kind of random url
and again you can hit that
and now i didn't run it for a while and
i think they're using kind of a low
resource environment so it will take
some time to spin up the first time
um
so it's kind of similar to if you're
using an app service plan you know the
free version it will
die when you're not using it
so it takes a few seconds the first time
you hit it
and the excitement is enormous
come on
and there we go
and you know it will work in the same
way here of course
but now he's running in in the cloud
somewhere uh and using industrial
container apps and again i didn't change
anything in my application
it just
actually just worked
so now it actually spins out the api
behind the scene now
so again if you're if you're trying to
insert the microservices and maybe don't
want to learn everything about
kubernetes which is actually kind of a
barrier to get into it's it's a
can be pretty complicated even though if
you have you have managed services like
aks in azure but you still need to know
a lot of things about kubernetes and
when you start getting errors you need
to understand a lot of things these are
the type of services that will be coming
a lot more now that will abstract these
these things away for you so they are
using kubernetes to host your things but
you can just deploy your apps and pay
for the amount of resources that you're
actually using
all right so
those few options actually just also a
slide on the on the sdk languages so i
showed you dot net core today but
there's a lot of
sdks for different types of languages
so you have a client sdk that's kind of
the basic of it that i showed you with
the you know the client and you can all
have this invoke methods
then you have for some of these
languages you have kind of an extra
things like the server extensions so for
asp.net core for example
uh it just makes it easier to to kind of
connect a few things and and you can
codify some things just more
more nicely you can inject that dapper
client for example and so on but again
you can use any language that you want
and
that's really one of the key points here
and again take a look at the the dapper
io site for more information
so for example
i could show you
um so if you go to the adapter
documentation sites you can for example
look at all these component specs that i
showed you
or i showed you some example of it so
for example if you're interested in in
the bindings to see i showed you the
twilio if you go in here you can see all
the existing binding components so here
you would for example see twilio down
here
and you can go in here and then you can
see the documentation on the on the
format or how you actually use these
things but again as you can see this is
a long list and just keeps growing
uh with things that you can communicate
now without actually having to write any
code to to do it
all right that's actually all that i had
we actually have two minutes left so if
there are any questions you can do it
now otherwise you can just come to me
after the session and ask there or ask
in the in the slack channel later on
um
but uh
i will just end by saying a big thank
you for for coming to my session i hope
you learned
something about dapper how it is how it
works and how you can get started with
it and if it's right the right tool for
you well you have to decide it for
yourself and
have a great rest of the conference
thank you
you